THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US, JACQUELENE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ALSO, YOU GUYS, FRED ARMISEN IS
BACK WITH US!
GIVE IT UP FOR FRED!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YOU LIVED THROUGH A FIVE-MONTH
WRITERS' STRIKE AND EVERYBODY
WHEN ITS OVER SAYS, "WHAT DID
YOU DO WITH YOUR TIME OFF?"
AND IT'S SOMETIMES EMBARRASSING
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
SHOW FOR IT.
FRED IS NOT LIKE THAT.
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A SECOND
OFF, YOU USE IT DO SOMETHING
IMPRESSIVE.
WE TALKED YESTERDAY ABOUT SOME
OF THE THINGS YOU ARE DOING.
AND THEN, I DIDN'T REALIZE THIS.
THAT YOU OPENED A NEW HAIR
SALON.
>> Fred: I DID.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Seth: I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT
WAS AN INTEREST OF YOURS.
>> Fred: I'M FASCINATED BY IT.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
FASCINATED.
>> Seth: AND WHAT -- I GUESS --
I MEAN, I HOPE THIS ISN'T A SORT
OF A NAIVE QUESTION TO ASK.
BUT WHAT MAKES YOURS DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER HAIR SALONS?
>> Fred: IT'S LIKE A MUSEUM
PIECE.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
SO, ITS HAIRSTYLES FROM THE
1000s.
YOU KNOW?
LIKE --
>> Seth: AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
CALL IT?
THEY CALL THEM THE 1000s?
>> Fred: YES.
>> Seth: OKAY.
>> Fred: SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO
AN EVENT YOU'RE CELEBRATING THE
1000s --
>> Seth: OKAY.
>> Fred: IT'S A WAY YOU COULD BE
ACCURATE.
>> Seth: OKAY.
OH, I SEE, SO LIKE IF YOU WENT
TO A FLAPPER PARTY AND YOU
WANTED TO HAVE A HAIRSTYLE LIKE
THE 1920s.
>> Fred: YES.
>> Seth: YOU WOULD NOT GO TO
YOUR HAIR SALON?
>> Fred: NO, NO.
SO, FOR THAT ONE, YOU'VE GOT TO
GO TO ONE OF THOSE THAT DO LIKE
1920s HAIRCUTS.
>> Seth: YEAH.
>> Fred: YOU KNOW LIKE THE
FLAPPER ONES.
>> Seth: GOTCHA.
>> Fred: THAT IS NOT WHAT I'M
RUNNING HERE.
>> Seth: GOTCHA.
BUT YOU DO COVER A WHOLE
100 YEARS.
LIKE IF SOMEONE WAS LIKE "I'M
GOING TO A PARTY THAT COVERS
1105."
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
>> Fred: THERE AREN'T A LOT OF
THOSE PARTIES.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
I DID THE RESEARCH TO KNOW THAT
LIKE, THAT'S NOT HAPPENING THAT
MUCH.
>> Seth: SORRY, BUT THERE ARE A
LOT OF PARTIES THAT COVER THE
THOUSANDS?
>> Fred: OH, TOO MANY.
WE'RE OPENING BRANCHES ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
JFK, LaGUARDIA.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
PENN STATION.
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> Seth: YOU KNOW, THAT'S
INTERESTING YOU MENTION TWO OF
THE AIRPORTS.
DO PEOPLE -- DO YOU FIND -- AND
AGAIN, MAYBE YOU DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE IT'S NOT A PLACE WHERE YOU
DO A LOT OF CHITCHAT.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE PEOPLE ARE ON
THERE WAY OUT OF TOWN TO GO TO A
1000s PARTY, AND STOP AT A HAIR
SALON RIGHT BEFORE THEY GO?
OR DO YOU THINK THEY'RE FLYING
IN FOR --
>> Fred: IN MY ESTIMATION?
I THINK THESE ARE AIRPORT
PARTIES THAT ARE HAPPENING.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
THAT'S WHAT I'M SEEING.
>> Seth: GOTCHA.
SO, IF YOU WERE HAVING A PARTY
TO CELEBRATE THE 1000s, YOU
THINK A GOOD PLACE TO HOLD IT
WOULD BE AN AIRPORT?
>> Fred: I DON'T HAVE THESE
PARTIES.
THIS IS OTHER PEOPLE.
I'M JUST -- THIS IS A BUSINESS.
>> Seth: SO, YOU DON'T JUDGE.
>> Fred: NO, THIS IS NOT ME.
>> Seth: YOU NEVER JUDGE.
>> Fred: NEVER.
I DON'T LIKE IT.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Seth: WHAT DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO JUDGE?
>> Fred: I'M A LITTE -- I'M NOT
INTO IT.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
WHEN THEY JUDGE.
I'M JUDGMENTAL OF THEM.
>> Seth: WELL, I CAN TELL HOW
PAINFUL IT WAS FOR YOU TO JUDGE
EVEN THEM.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Fred: YES.
>> Seth: WHAT IS THE NAME OF THE
PLACE?
>> Fred: WE DON'T HAVE A NAME.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
IN THE 1000s THEY DIDN'T HAVE
NAMES FOR THINGS.
>> Seth: IN THE 1000s THEY
DIDN'T HAVE NAMES FOR THINGS?
>> Fred: OF COURSE NOT.
IT WAS THE EARLY DAYS.
SO FEW PEOPLE.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Seth: EVEN THE PEOPLE DIDN'T
HAVE NAMES?
>> Fred: NO.
THERE WERE SO FEW OF THEM, IT
WAS JUST LIKE.
YOU JUST KNEW EACH OTHER.
>> Seth: GOTCHA.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
SO, LET'S SAY YOU AND I ARE
NEIGHBORS IN THE